there's a kid called uh trevor wallace
you ever seen this guy he killed him
this kid's great man i watch all his
content sketches he's the sketches
now what are your thoughts on you know
youtubers tick talkers
becoming
comedians or you know kind of getting
into that because i've heard sometimes
they suck and stand up i've seen it yeah
mostly they suck exactly what are your
thoughts on that this guy trevor is
pretty damn good yeah he's a funny guy
obviously but stand up is a different
animal you know it's like saying hey
this guy's a hell of a boxer it's like
all right well can you do mma you know
so
uh these guys are funny but they're
videotaped and it's edited and they put
clips and graphics and [ __ ] so it's a
different animal than you get in front
of a live audience and you have to do 45
minutes and get laughs every 30 seconds
now now it's a different ball game so uh
i say do what you got to do as long as
you take it seriously a lot of guys like
these chris katans or whoever will be
like hey i can sell tickets i was on snl
for years and then they do seven minutes
and talk about old stories and they have
no act right and i get it's a cash grab
but like
stevo apparently is taking it seriously
i think oh really so that to me that's
all that matters just treat it like it
should be treated yes i'll tell you what
uh it seems like you've got no problem
naming names well i just try to keep it
real i'm not i'm not trying to do what
i'm saying i respect the hell out of
that oh like you just called out chris
kattan who you know well i think he's in
a in a bathtub right now crying so i'm
not too worried about it i'm just i'm
just being honest like i don't i don't
think kattan would say hey i'm i'm
working hard and writing jokes like
gotcha i think he would agree with me
gotcha
sorry about like tick tock people like
use insights right that's the entire
trend
if you can tap into an insight and put a
caption on it in six seconds it'll go to
see
58.5 million people but taking insights
and presenting them without any visual
aid is a whole different way what do you
mean by insects actually on your
instagram yeah no people make a joke by
talking about an insight that everyone
can relate to and adding a visual meme
with a caption over it and people are
like oh this happened to me send share
share share share but to do it without
any visual component or an audio track
that already gives you half the battle
if you pick a song that relates to a
time period and a picture that relates
to a whole thing and then you just put a
caption on it you've created this
trifecta that you can't [ __ ] do on
stage here here well said he's been
pointing at you and agreeing with you
for the past 30 seconds yeah wha what
did she nail you nailed it it's it's
because there's an algo situation going
on with the with the internet you know
whereas can you stand in front of people
and plant your feet and get involuntary
laughter from an original thought or an
original joke i doubt it but you can
figure out what's trending and what's
hashtagging and all that i'm so i sound
like some boomer weirdo but these
algorithms you know these kids you
haven't ventured into tick tock twitter
is your main twitter instagram i have a
guy i pay now because i'm like i guess
you got to do this so i just toss it off
to some young page
to do tick tock i'm like here's some
videos you upload it you put the right
banner the right caption the right
graphics and you know it's some you know
youngster and he knows what he's doing
gotcha
uh well that comes with success you can
hire youngsters start doing some [ __ ]
they're here but the tick-tock comedians
have the following to sell out small
shows because they already have millions
of followers exactly so if you can use
it to your advantage i'm trying no yeah
i'm not knocking it
[Music]